yeah we don't have any instruments today
unfortunately we have the instruments of
our voice severe oversight I'm not about
to sing a song
hi everybody Welcome to the quarter
podcast today it's Fenner Dean and
myself Nico sitting on the couch no Jake
today it's just us
AI boys
hey congrats on uh such an awesome video
dropping this past weekend guys thank
you thanks man that was uh very proud of
it it was really fun to work on yeah and
you can tell we're both super tired
I don't know yeah I think uh Dean and I
burned the candle a little bit there
both ends it's uh I don't know it's easy
to do that when you're having fun and
during like doing cool stuff and
learning a ton yep and the first you
know we're seeing the reactions people
seem very positive about it you know I'm
glad people are pulling out all the
Easter eggs we stuck in there and stuff
and uh has big Spider-Man fans I think
it was
super fun to put that all in there and I
think uh hopefully it came across well I
mean I think that you guys
I've currently done the best
artistic creation with stable diffusion
in my opinion like not to like rank
everything in the world but
you know a lot of people have been
generating images of stable diffusion
and doing experiments but in my opinion
you guys are kind of the first ones to
go out there and not only create a
finished product I mean other people
have created finished products but you
did so in a way where
you know having having a different
picture for every frame actually makes
sense in the story that you guys are
doing and it's visually captivating and
it's just one small part of an actual
like creative hole of a piece that you
guys made you know it's not like hey I
applied a filter to a video and now it's
art like yeah you guys did there's been
a lot of um stuff there has been a lot
of videos made with stable diffusion but
pretty much all of it has been
uh uh I don't know what plugins called
but you can essentially have each frame
denoise the last frame yeah deform and
you can uh we've done it you can create
animations these really trippy like
psychedelic animations that will just
plunge further and further into this you
know endless image of AI gobble League
you know but uh I you know I do think
we're the first people to make something
that has some consistency and it's not
just uh you know hallucination yeah yeah
there's a very small overlap between
like actual visual effects artists and
people using AI for Generation like
synthesized media there's a couple of
them out there but like there's not that
many of them out there yeah it was like
Dina because this was your idea to be
like what if we did some spider burst
thing and as soon as you said that I was
like oh we yeah this is like the perfect
idea for this where you're like okay we
can have this very distinct art style
which also has a history of being like
multiversal in nature so it's like hey
we can use it to have all these cool
different art styles and different
characters it was honestly we found
through the process like perfect for it
because yeah so much of spider versus
based on glitches and
um you know changing art styles and
stuff like that and it was kind of
it was a good mask for us to hide all of
the little inconsistencies with the AI
but yeah like I hope like the biggest
goal with the video I think is like for
somebody to watch it and have no idea
that there was AI touching it and I did
see plenty of comments where somebody
would respond like hey oh no this was
actually you know AI or whatever because
people thought it was animation like oh
this was the best fan animation I've
seen in a while or something like that
so I mean the ribs have already started
people cutting out all of our stuff and
then just be like new leaked scene from
across the spider verse yeah and you
know thankfully like the first comment
mostly was like hey this is corridor's
video but every a few you know layers
down you find the whoa crazy and it's
like oh they bought it yeah but I think
it's also it's really easy to
underestimate how much actual like work
went into it because also watching the
the side by sides that you posted Penner
on your Instagram and on the quarter
Instagram like a lot of the shots I
thought were just like spider-verse
shots it's like some extra work put onto
them but they're full on like Composites
taken from original Spider-Man films
that have nothing to do with
spider-verse yeah all that stuff is
added new graphics are generated yep
like full on yeah getting into it Dean
and I were kind of like man we can't
just cut stuff out and put it in so it
was like every single shot except for
the one shot at the start where Peter
turns around and goes like huh every
single one is like a VFX shot so it
ended up being a lot of work but it was
uh it was really rewarding and like man
that last day when we were working on it
and we got it to a point where we're
like it's done let's just spend like
four hours polishing it that was so much
fun
you know it's great but but also I think
that was part of the the joy of the
process is like we talk about it in the
crew video but like
looking at the spider verse film and
figuring out like I mean obviously it's
such a it's such a creative achievement
that movie you know just from there's
like animation CG animation before
spider-verse and there's CG animation
after spider verse and um we've had
guests on the on the react show Alex
snow who talks a lot about this of
how CG animation these days is really
starting to push it's like a new era
it's like they're starting to push uh
the appeal of these uh of these
animations each frame having it look
like a painting rather than it being a a
shortcut for animation because the thing
is like with
um you know with classic 2D animation
you can't get shading and you can't get
you know uh complex you know depth
geometric structure geometric structure
and I think they uh we did an episode
about Klaus the uh the Netflix uh 2D
animated film
it was using I think a process in Nuke
to add a whole depth lighting pass to
the characters and the director of the
film was saying like this this didn't
used to be possible and we used to look
at the DVD covers of
uh
uh you know like
animated films from the 80s and 90s and
be like I wish we could make the movie
look like that like the the the way
animation was done like it wasn't an
intentional
thing to have it look flat you know it's
like if they had the option they would
have given it depth you know and like CG
gives you that ability to do that in a
reasonable amount of time
but I think
a lot of Studios got caught up in the in
the tech and they lost the like
principles of Animation yeah you know
and spider-verse brought that back and
so like like going frame by frame
through that film it's just sort of like
every frame is and this was their
attention every frame was just gorgeous
and like so sculpted one of the coolest
things from watching some of the
spider-verse behind the scenes is the um
the supervisor on it was saying you can
pause that movie and every single frame
is legible which is so cool because they
didn't use motion blur yeah occasionally
it's used when like to really make it a
moment and then when they do it's like
this stepy kind of like almost frame
blending thing or even they use uh like
smearing yeah you know like having
doubling up on the arm as it's moving
but it's like every frame is so clear
and it's I don't know it was I don't
know that movie the first time I watched
it was still it blew my mind and was
super inspiring so just when we were
like had our opportunity to be like
let's just do something kind of like
inspired by this using this and I don't
know it was so cool to kind of create
our own little Adventure within that
like art style and universe like it was
super cool yeah so when Fenner when you
were working with other companies how
much like granted like the AI machine
learning landscape changed a lot in like
the past six months but when you're
working at the other companies how much
much like was machine learning part of
your pipeline there very little like I
think it's just starting to kind of roll
into some studios but that is like the I
don't know the
probably one of the worst parts of
larger scale Studios is they're such an
established pipeline that any sort of
change is very slow
so you know it's getting there but I
remember I have a really good friend of
mine
um Mike asachura he was really early to
the Deep fake thing I
yeah so he was like very early on and he
um
he had a really hard time just being
like hey guys can I use this software to
do deep fakes because we have a shot
that we need to replace someone's face
with another actor and they're like yeah
well okay we'll try to get it set up
like
um that's not exactly the same but it
you know it's the same process of like
just having
it's it's not really that present I mean
there's r d departments at every big
Studio that's starting to roll that
stuff in but it's been really nice at
Corridor just being like sweet let's use
magic mask it's awesome it's not perfect
but God damn it's good right yeah but
yeah Dean basically rolled magic mask
like Roto just mats out for every single
shot so yeah it's like we edited the
piece together and then in like 10
minutes I had most of the shots like
yeah and it was like you know there's
little pops here and there and we kind
of were able again like you said hide
behind it with the spider-verse stuff
but yeah and it's like it worked given
time like given another five minutes
twice as long 10 minutes instead of five
yeah exactly which is just like man
having like this piece would have been
possible without machine learning we
wouldn't have been able to do that
without magic mask yeah
and Benjamin magic mask oh yeah yeah uh
Magic mask is DaVinci Resolve they just
rolled it into their actual Fusion
pipeline but it was traditionally in
their color page it's basically just uh
like AI generated Roto you basically do
a couple little squiggles
hit play and it sort of figures out what
to extract from your scene and it's
Blackmagic Wizardry it's straight up
magic because and that's why they call
it that if you've heard of rotobrush
with After Effects you've used it this
is basically rotor brush times 100 it
which calculates 100 times faster
brush 2 is really good but this is like
you literally just draw a line on a
person and it's like you could pretty
much get
a perfect mask if if especially if it's
just like subject and a background yeah
it just Nails it every time and um yeah
it's just it so much of this AI stuff
you know we've we've talked a lot about
this is it is it
takes all of the boring [ __ ] out of the
process yes every hating on it doesn't
realize it's taking all the boring crap
out that we don't like doing yeah yeah
it's like well you're gonna take this
Roto you know artist's job where I had
to sit there for eight hours and and
hand cut out a frame it's like no now
that person can do something creative
you know instead of just uh yeah grunt
labor yeah and I think I think that was
something you got across really well in
the crew video like that crew video you
edited together in like two days
because you were editing the actual
short it turned out so well and I I love
you like the discussion you guys had
just about the ethics of AI in that and
what I think we tried to get across in
the video was that it's a tool it's I
don't think it's going to be this Doom
and Gloom take every artist job thing
it's going to hopefully enable people to
be more creative and yeah I mean like if
you again going back to those wipes that
you have it's like those are you're just
using assets those are it's like
anything else it's just the computer has
generated something that is really close
to what you want but you still have to
take it and manipulate it yeah match the
colors you know do all kinds of things
and it's it's I don't
I mean we said this a few months about a
go about video but like I don't know
that it'll be ever at the point where
you just click a button and you're and
you're done with it and that's that's
such a boring concept to me at least as
like like uh especially like first
getting into stable diffusion like after
we made our death of VFX video I was
like holy crap that was when I really
had the moment of like this is gonna
change everything getting into it
immediately I was bored by like text to
image like just typing something in an
image comes out it's like this is so
cool but it doesn't mean anything to me
personally it's about as boring as stock
stock imagery yeah yeah and like
it's just really cool looking stock
image sometimes yeah that's it the first
thing for me that that I was like oh I
love this it was discovering image
damage where you could give it an input
image and you basically have a slider of
zero being the original image one being
purely random you know based on the
prompt and like you can actually start
to mix a process of like you know giving
in an original input image and then
putting that in Photoshop and then
taking it back and in painting and doing
all these different things and getting
it to be exactly what you want in a
super short amount of time yeah you know
and I I guess I do I do understand the
very the more traditional artists like
hesitation towards it where it's like
yeah you know
it is this weird gray area of it is
copying styles for sure
you know I've seen some really cool art
in the style of guys like Greg gracowski
that he didn't create but it's like
and like I could see like traditional
concept artists as well that's
definitely something that I think that
industry will have a bit of a weird
shift but
I guess my perspective on it is that if
I was a working as a professional
concept artist right now I'd be like
sweet I'm gonna really try to learn this
tool and you know yeah cool this will
save me some time drawing the mountains
because you're gonna have to draw the
actual Concepts yes exactly right it's
not you can't just type in some words
and get your unique Vision it's like you
said it's like it's creating assets and
maybe that helps you display 10
different versions of something to a
client and they can just iterate and
it'll just make that process better I I
did see one guy on LinkedIn who's a
concept artist and he trained a dream
Booth model on all of his own concept
art that's cool that's cool and he was
like this is awesome yeah he's like it
just gives me this starting point of
like I'll just do like a batch of five
and then I'm like I like that one I'm
gonna work off that it's like just to
yeah it's it's so much I mean it's
really funny because a lot of concept
art is taking existing images yeah
cutting things out and putting them in
place and like you know I can't wait for
the day that uh a program like Photoshop
or something has an incorporated tool
that is like the stable diffusion
paintbrush which is just like you know
you have your image you can you know
Auto Select an object and be like I want
to change it to this and just sort of
like
continually get closer to what you want
but again it's like
I am just so bored by the idea that it
like the thing that people fear which is
like uh you're just gonna type something
when something comes out like and I
think
that's why like
you know video is pushing that even
farther because you have to like
spider-verse you have to make sure every
frame is what you want and that's
thousands and thousands of pictures so
it it'll never get to the point where
I'll Never Say Never
like it's not gonna happen in the next
year yeah but yeah up to two weeks later
that you won't want to have like a human
voice coming through the thing even if
most of it's AI it's funny that you're
talking about this because like right
now I'm doing all the prep for the video
we're shooting tomorrow which is uh what
was the title that you came up with
again is uh how did how to tell who's
real on the internet yeah something like
that like that basically this video is
it's a it's a it's a discussion about
how to spot fake videos slash AI
generated videos and one of the segments
is going to be looking at art uh
basically stable diffusion ART versus
real art and I was like okay well for
the segment you know we were talking
about this idea of like why don't we
started off with a guessing game we put
two pictures up you guess which one's AI
which one's the real thing cool well I'm
gonna kick things off I'm gonna get some
Greg grotkowski pictures and I'll
generate some Greg Rakowski pictures so
I went like here's a cool dragon picture
here's a cool night fighting another
night you know whatever I grab some cool
pictures from his art station page and
like okay hop over to stable Fusion
start typing in you know the red vegan
by painted by Greg gracowski in like
every single one is garbage I thought
it'd be like ah you know I can get
something kind of close like no like
literally getting a cohesion just just a
cohesive dragon and nothing else is
nearly impossible did you try any image
to image ones I did because that's
cheating that's when you started images
just yeah actually drawing something now
yeah you know with the help of like you
know that's at that point it's like not
everything like photoshopping like here
let you know here's some tools to tweak
your colors or like you know fix minds
but like
yeah like to actually generate something
that's anywhere close to Greg Rakowski
is currently impossible yeah uh and it's
a long ways away and it's like what
about those great pictures of people's
faces I see it's like cool like if I
give you a model if I give you like a
hundred thousand images of a human face
I can trade an AI to give you one more
image of a human face and it's gonna
look fine but the moment you want
something unique the moment you want
like a special face tattoo yeah you know
it's done it doesn't work you know it's
like I specifically want this Scar and I
want it to be the same scar when the
face is turned a little bit you know
it's like nope no way it's not gonna
work even like I was trying Van Gogh
like you'd think all right you know you
can mimic Van Gogh style pretty easily
right no yeah no like it's close to like
the really untrained eye it's close but
the moment you scrutinize it just a
little bit you're like yeah it lacks
concept and Direction and structure and
you know it's like it just really falls
apart it's kind of a terrifying thing
zooming into AI art because it's um
it's really just like looking at a dream
or something yeah the second that you
start to uh break it open it's like does
it even it this isn't even anything it's
actually yeah like the the core of this
is just
random stuff again the cartooning you
know it's like cartooning is like what's
the minimum number of lines and shapes I
can put down to like to create emotion
you know it's like oh those two blobs in
that one other blob definitely anger
yeah well it was so funny like because
we would be generating these random just
frames for glitch frames and stuff and
you'd be like Spider-Man climbing a
building and then it's just like some
red and blue squished on some gray and I
was like if I squint that's Spider-Man
like yeah if you squish if it flashes
for one frame it's Spider-Man but like a
lot of those individual frames is just
like weirdness like it's yeah I mean in
a way it's almost like the way
a human artist would work is that you
draw the broad Strokes first and like
the AI is working from a perspective of
like I every pixel is going to come out
at once and it's gonna be something I've
seen before you know it's not sort of
like
you know drawing each stroke one at a
time
yeah
so it's interesting like I'm really
starting to feel the tool right yeah the
whole concept of like we're on this
precipice of mankind like you know
destroying itself on the mountains of
you know like that's not happening
anymore now it's like okay this is I see
where this fits in it's like it's like
fancy Photoshop yeah you know it's like
really this is not this is not a uh
industry killer it's like it's you know
certainly a a good taste of what machine
learning is going to bring us but what
machine learning is bringing us is not
the death of the artist The Machine
learning is is machine learning is
bringing us the death of tedium you know
it's it's like awesome like if I like we
don't we don't deride Christopher Nolan
for not touching a camera
you know it's like you know Steven
Spielberg doesn't necessarily write his
scripts like we don't deride and like oh
you just pushed a button your money
button and you got a script and you
filmed it yeah I didn't even film it you
hired somebody else to actually hold the
camera you just stood there and pushed a
button and he's like you don't say that
about them it's like because there's
obviously so much to actually still
making something outside of like
actually having to physically make it
and the AI is the same thing where it's
like cool I pushed a button and it gave
me a good picture of a mountain
too bad that's not a story yeah you know
I still need to take that image of a
mountain now and insert it into my work
of art and work on the composition and
create my story and figure out why you
even give a crap that there's a mountain
in my picture in the first place like
AI is not replacing any of that you know
well and I think that's
possibly the thing that people are
afraid of like I recognize for sure that
there is the element of like it it could
be seen as like stealing somebody's art
style but there's also the like
gatekeeping aspect of it which is like I
went to art school and I have uh you
know I am accredited to tell people
stories and I can't have just some
random kid on his laptop on Google
collab you know making uh making cool
stuff and
you know we talk about it in the crew
video but it there is there is of course
a line where you're just into the
stealing mode but we uh I kind of made
this analogy in the video but like when
hip-hop
first started as an art form the music
industry didn't see it as music they
were like this is this is just they're
just using music yeah other music and
talking over it you know and it's only
now that we see like oh that is a it is
its own art form and like when somebody
samples a song like you know
Kanye West you know
sorry he's uh
but you know those uh those songs like
are
such a creative use of samples yeah to
the point where it's totally
transformative like taking taking the uh
like there's one song where he takes the
the instrumental noodling at like the
beginning of the song like two seconds
of it and that's No Church in the Wild
yeah you know and uh it's like doing
that with with AI I think is really the
exciting thing is like taking
just a nugget of something and then
making that into a whole new thing or
you know
but but yeah I that's how I think of it
that's where the Artistry comes in yeah
it's like yeah I took this little two
second sample but I made a whole track
out of it or I took this I don't know
like weirdly generated like cowboy
doctor strange and somehow turned that
into a scene in a thing but you have to
actually
yeah it's Niko you were saying I guess
that was last week or a couple weeks ago
it's all blur now but you were talking
about just getting to a point where it's
like using these tools to tell a unique
story and that's like that's what's so
awesome about this stuff is it just it
breaks down that barrier to entry I mean
just open source Tools in general are
free tools like you know stuff like
blunders like man if you want to make
some cool animated scene go do that then
run it through stable diffusion and like
it's it's so cool like it's all just to
me it's like bringing like breaking down
that barrier to entry a little bit which
is nice yeah yeah for sure I mean
everybody likes likes drama you know and
we've all watched Terminator two so it's
like you know we could be like uh hey hi
it's Senti and my job is at risk it's me
versus the machines now like you know
obviously people like to indulge in that
uh that fantasy a little bit but you
know the other thing I'm reminded of as
we talk about all this is like no one
actually decides what art is no one
makes the rules like no one gets to be
like
you can like that that's not how art is
made it's like if you like it you like
it it's for everybody else exactly so
what yeah yeah
yeah well I and then kind of going oh
going off the point of you know people
in art school being kind of Gatekeepers
I think there's also this thing is art
school was that what are you against Art
School well the gatekeeping I went to
art school but you haven't been
gatekeeping you've opened the gates for
the people you open the gates for like
Penner yeah
and that's the cool like sharing
knowledge is the cool thing but like
kind of telling people like hey you
can't do that you know there's rules
here it just feels
I just feel like this might be a kind of
separate thing but there was this whole
thing where people were telling like
coal miners to learn how to code uh-huh
you know and the whole like when when AI
uh automation you know all those fears
started Rising it was like oh the truck
drivers are going to lose all their jobs
but the second hit people in art schools
they're like I'm not gonna learn how to
use this freaking program is that what
do you mean I'm gonna draw with my hand
the way I always have that's been the
thing that is like I guess my biggest
like
I don't know conflict with it is yeah it
is kind of like yeah it's a new tool
unfortunately you gotta learn it like
yeah and not unfortunately it's like
you're this is awesome you get to learn
this like it's yeah and so yeah it's
just this kind of thing where
people want there's this split of like
you want your art to be like so
representative of what you like and and
and what you feel deep down but also
it's
it is something you provide to a
community right it is a it is a it's a
uh commodity or it's like a it's a thing
that you are giving to others to like
improve their lives just the way like
cooking food for somebody is so if
there's a better way to do it to bring
it to more people literally nobody
complains about us having magic masks
and yeah and nobody complains about us
shooting on digital instead of film
Nobody complains about us using green
screens instead of cutting things out by
hand like yeah
in like stable diffusion or any AI
generated stuff it's like it's like
building a video game it's not building
the video game for you it's just giving
you a texture for like the grass yeah
it's like ah perfect I needed a texture
for the grass and rather than having to
go outside and take a picture off the
grass I can just type in Grass texture
it's like that's what it's doing for you
it's not video game level it's like you
can't type that in just get something
it's just it's like it's objects it's
just giving you little objects and stock
footage and that's all so amped because
like like me too I have to screw around
with all that yeah like we're all like
sci-fi heavy you know people fantasy
heavy people and it's like you have
these stories in your head that you like
I can't ever tell that story because I
don't have 150 million dollars yeah yeah
but like if I have the ability to just
you know
like we're talking about with all these
free programs like blender unreal like
it's opening up the floodgates of like
you know and even if everybody's able to
do it it's like at least I could tell
the story that's in my head before I die
you know it's like all these stories
that you thought about since you're a
kid it's like I might actually get to
like make those in my free time like
like a painter would yeah uh like a
painter would paint a painting it's like
maybe film has just been gonna become
like painting where it's like anybody
can do it you know I mean that's that's
the biggest thing for me with all of
this is it just it enables you to make
more cool stuff like and it's working on
the spider first thing together I was
like dude we can do such cool stuff like
yeah again that was I think it was a
little bit of like perfect use case for
it but I think we can
yeah going forward it's only gonna get
you know the the pace has been insane I
sent Nico something the other day but my
dad had a freaking
we were joking about how it was going to
become an iPhone app like we were
playing around with it and then I like
saw my parents and my dad was using
basically an implementation of dream
Booth that's just like an iPhone app wow
yeah which was made by the guy that
actually started the Discord yeah right
towards yeah and uh so I was like wow
this is already out there you know it's
already you know easily available and
you know as much like because for us
like the work on the Spider-Man short
was like a lot of that is just
representative of you know the things
that we've learned
about filmmaking like it's not just AI
but like the AI stuff in it
you know I don't I don't honestly know
that much about like stable diffusion
I've learned a ton about it in the past
month or so but they're still like
really basic things where I'm like I
don't know how that works but
it's like it's really not that hard to
use yeah and like well it's it's kind of
I always
feel the same way with using different
tools and stuff but then I kind of think
I'm like you know I don't actually know
how like a paintbrush works you know
like I'm like I don't you don't do long
oil painting yeah it's like you know
yeah it's like I understand there's
paint and there's a brush but it's like
yeah this just you know it's you don't
it's this weird thing that I've always
struggled with it's like this balance of
being a technical
artist and it's like versus a creative
artist and it's like I think as long as
you can understand how to use the tools
you don't need to understand how this is
there's a balance there for sure yeah we
had talked about this a little bit where
you were kind of like
I could be keeping up with all of this
because it the pace of the tech is
moving so fast like I could be keeping
up with all of this and then in two
weeks it could be
like a click of a button and really easy
to use rather than like I have to open
Anaconda be careful about how much time
you spent solving problems yeah because
there are teams of people solving the
problems at the actual companies that
know what they're doing you know it's
like yeah
you know like the temporal consistency
thing right you're trying to get so it
doesn't flicker fairy frame so you sit
there like all right here's a new
process and a new method if I do this
and I make this pipeline hey this kind
of works all right let's let's get the
rest of the team trained up on this
pipeline cool we have a whole workflow
going it's all dialed in don't change a
thing now I can shoot a whole project
around this new pipeline let's go two
months later you finally have a cartoon
a full-blown cartoon that you shot with
cameras so it still took a lot of work
but now you did it and it's like and
then like a week later they're like
companies like okay here's a new method
works great just click a button yeah
even you posted that example that new
test today and I was the thing I noticed
right away was like the eyes were so
consistent that was probably the biggest
thing we had jumping around like was
that a new process you're doing yeah uh
I don't know if we should talk about it
too much so here's the thing it's like
this is a world of Open Source and
sharing knowledge right but I don't want
to share it until I get the video out
yeah yeah at least I get at least a
couple weeks we did the same thing with
the Spider-Man video we're like we can't
tell anybody and then when the videos I
will tell everybody we'll show you
exactly how to do it but like uh there's
just a fun thing of like you know it's
cool to be the person like figure it out
first especially when every two weeks
it's like 100 times better
uh it it does feel Cutting Edge right
now and like and it's that's a really
fun aspect of it is like I'm sure
in a year it'll be so
so well implemented in all these
programs that it won't feel new right
now but like again like you're talking
about there's these massive companies
with like hundreds of millions of
dollars in r d and like here we are on
this YouTube channel it's like we're
doing stuff that you know Hollywood
films aren't doing and it's like well
that's only what that's the only reason
like Corridor has survived as like a
company is because because we can do
things faster and like you know
obviously like I'm sure there's somebody
at ilm messing around a stable diffusion
you know it's like
you know cool but like even if they
actually did something really nuts with
it and they implemented into work well
you're not going to see it for two years
you know because it just it takes that
long for things to get finished I love
that analogy of like it's like ships in
the ocean a giant container ship takes
forever to turn but if you're in just on
a jet ski like the corridor digital jet
ski like oh sweet stable diffusion yeah
shred over there like yeah and you get a
little bit of time to play around in
that water before that big cargo ship
gets there but it'll get there swamps
yeah so it's like we just have that
ability to be like
you know just said go out there and try
it and then
it's in our blood it's kind of how
Corridor started it's like okay here's a
cool visual tool well you know I we
don't learn the visual tools because we
like learning visual tools we learn the
visual tools because we want to make
stuff with them you know yeah and so
it's like so then we go you make
something with it but it just takes a
few weeks and you just do it quick and
it's casual you're not worried about it
being perfect and you know suddenly it's
out there it's also the best way to
learn something is like diving into a
project because if yeah like uh like
this year I've been like learning 3D and
I had tried you know every few years I
would open the the blender donut and I
would do it and I'm like I'm not there's
no hook here but the second I was like
you know around you guys and everybody's
like you know do this a render or like
like I'm gonna make a little thing and
that's gonna be you know for these
videos that we do I was like oh I'll
just make something I'll just my goal
will be to make something and if there's
something I want to do
I'll just Google it and learn how to do
it and that's like I mean at least for
the YouTube generation that's like
how we've learned everything this is
just the the knowledge is all available
and
you know
I was I was even thinking about with
with YouTube like the idea that you can
make a vlog edit it together like Casey
neistat like you could make a vlog edit
it together and put out a like 15 minute
video that is a whole story with footage
and everything like imagine telling
somebody in the 20s that you could do
that imagine talking something in the
80s in the 80s yeah you think that's so
for granted now that you just film
something and edit it it's like
non-linear editor is like weren't
invented until the 90s like it hasn't
been around that long and I was like
whatever
like who cares yeah and imagine what the
future of this stuff is that like the
YouTubers you love it's not that you're
watching like Vlogs you're watching a
full animated uh episode of Television
like every week from your favorite
creators yeah well I mean like let's say
a tool like like magic mask comes along
it's like hey this this divides like
this decimates like literally this takes
one tenth as long to do something now
that used to take me a lot longer so I
can go out and do the exact same shot
that major Studio would do but I need
one 10th of the man hours or one tenth
of the Manpower
and so that means if I go out and I do a
little short that has 10 effect shots in
it like I can do this at Studio level
you know and and with a team of my size
and you go out and you do it and you get
done just out there I was like wow you
just did the thing that Disney can't do
or whatever you know it's like great a
Disney can do it give another year like
you know like I said there's that slow
thing happening but like
it's just being able to get out there
and do it and do it quick and just move
on to the next and trying things it's
it's really a really awesome spot to be
in and the like the online audience is
like just like us they have embraced the
Jank like people are okay with Jank
these days uh you know something's not
perfect doesn't matter if the concept's
cool it doesn't matter if you're just
authentically trying to make something
cool like no one's going on like Joel
haver's videos and being like your lines
popped yeah
I truly I had not heard of uh Joel Haver
until this week and I have been binging
his videos and they're so funny man the
like RPG ones it's just that perfect
perfectly captures and like the his
animation style using ubisynth is like
it gets and you always talk about this
with the old quarter videos is like it
gets the idea across like the execution
is good enough that you on you get what
it's going for and like that's truly all
all that matters because like yeah we
could we could have like gone in and
fixed Peter's eyes on every frame of him
animated in in that short but it's like
but the video still wouldn't be out yeah
and then like through that it will never
be like perfect but we got it to the
point where it got the idea across you
know the idea that we're going for yeah
the the crazy thing just going back to
Joel Haver is like you're saying it's
like it's good enough to get the idea
across but then that idea becomes so
like good and so relatable that now that
art style becomes oh that's the Joel
Haver art style and there's other
YouTube channels now that are like just
doing his art style yeah it's crazy it's
like and there's a charm there's a
there's an added joke in some of what
that art style provides to his videos
because like a little bit of that Jank
is kind of funny yeah you know
yeah style matters yeah it does matter
like
you can't present a very clean hyper
polished style and have jankiness in it
right you do need to have it match the
vibe of what you're presenting
um but that said it's like if you can't
achieve a perfectly Crystal Clear
cinematic style and be like okay well
that's not my style yeah you know
I don't know if you guys have seen the
new Black Panther yet but there's a
sequence in it where it's I found it
super jarring it was cutting between
this was really weird too it was cutting
between the IMAX aspect ratio and like a
cinematic aspect ratio from shot to shot
that's weird which was because usually
it's like oh this is an iMac sequence
cool but it was from shot to shot it was
super weird that is really weird it's
super jarring and then one of them was
very clearly
like not that it was bad but it was blue
screen like set wait give me uh because
I've seen it what what part are you
generally talking about the kind of big
finale battle oh okay yeah oh geez yeah
yeah and then and then it would cut to
the other kind of battle happening and
it's like this beautiful slow-mo
cinematic in like practical sand yeah
like it's like all like super shallow
depth of field into like wide locked off
camera on blue screen I was like what is
happening like it was super jarring and
it was like if you're going to have that
polished like this is Cinema
it was super jarring to then jump to
like ah this is very VFX heavy well like
blue screen comp to tie that in a spider
verse that's like why I love that movie
so much because so many comic book
movies are like
especially Marvel Marvel is like split
between two Styles which is and there
there are times
you know I've looked at these movies
super closely over the years because
we've been making these React videos and
stuff and there's uh there's a specific
scene in Civil War where uh it's like uh
the airport scene and Iron Man and
Captain America first like meet up in
the middle of this airport which all
looks like it's shot on a green screen
you know but you can tell
that Iron Man is looking One Direction
before you know before Spider-Man shows
up he's looking One Direction and it's
very serious like and the Very cinematic
lighting and like it's very uh like part
of the tone that I liked about that
movie which is more of like a political
thriller
and then when Spider-Man shows up and
they cut to Iron Man's reactions when he
turns you can tell
there's he's got like maybe a wig on or
something I was like trying to you know
make his hair look like it did during
that shoot flatter lighting and it's all
the quips
and you can tell with these movies that
they do this like joke pass or this like
I don't take this seriously pass and
that's with the Marvel films it's like
what I what really pulls me out of it is
that
there's so much undercutting the
gravitas of the situation by characters
being like none of this makes sense you
know yeah and um
and yeah and I think
whereas spider verse like tonally was
just it never did that even though it
had tons of quips tons of humor even
like fourth wall breaking stuff in the
beginning they talk about like the
Spider-Man popsicle yeah but there's no
moment during the final battle where
somebody's like this is dumb don't take
this seriously yeah you know yeah it
that's I think my biggest issue with
Marvel as well it's like it's like here
are the stakes yeah they don't really
matter though here's a goof like yeah
and yeah it's kind of this weird
this weird thing that
I don't know it definitely takes away
from those movies yeah and I miss the
days of like super earnest
Adventure films you know of and that's
the stuff that I find myself gravitating
more and more towards like you know
movies that came out when I was younger
that were like
they just they went fully into it and
they're they're you know like um
what are some movies that came out
recently like the Batman uh took itself
there's no undercutting of of the world
of the care that the characters live in
I think Dune did that you know it's just
there's a lot of these
hopefully more uh big budget movies are
gonna come out and stop doing this like
there's got to be a joke every five
seconds thing yeah I feel like Dune was
a great example of that it's like here's
the world you're going to be in this
like here's the style yeah like it was
very well done yeah there's no like hey
this guy's wearing a weird outfit by
somebody in the movie you know I mean
just we just need to wait for filmmaking
to democratize a little bit more you
know yeah it's like being able to
explore those kind of Storytelling ideas
narrative is really hard to do right you
have to build worlds you have to build
characters you have to deal with acting
and like not everybody's an actor not
everybody looks like the character they
want never really sounds like the
character they want even if they can
emote correctly let alone direct and
write well or shoot something like
if we're close we're getting there
you know something I've I've been
thinking about is like you know so many
companies that exist off of user
generated content and as we're seeing
not just with machine learning and AI
but just with all the tools that we're
using like it's becoming easier and
easier and easier for people to make
content and it's not necessarily easy
but it's becoming easier
but so many of these companies have
become multi-billion com dollar
companies purely riding off the backs of
all the people making content for their
platforms and
you have something you have someone like
YouTube who I think has done a really
solid job of working with the people
that make content on their platforms
right I don't feel exploited by YouTube
at all right yeah but then you have
other companies like Facebook or Tick
Tock that in my opinion very much
exploit people and tick tock's the
biggest for audience and the request for
you know having somebody to like absorb
their art yeah is that cool you make all
the content we'll keep all the money
yeah and it's weird that like in a world
where people talk about people being
exploited people kind of just I feel
like you hear Rumblings of it but people
really kind of turn a blind eye towards
something like Tick Tock or Facebook
where they've literally made billions of
dollars and they haven't given any of it
to the reason they the people that made
it so they could have billions of
dollars which is the people making
content like well and also on Tick Tock
it's like there's just a top run of like
for if it's like the dancing tick tocks
or whatever like there's one girl who's
making all the money and then all of
these other people don't get anything
and she's like using their dances and
all all this stuff and it's just it is
kind of the lowest common denominator of
all these platforms uh whereas like
you're saying like YouTube it feels so
much more democratic where you can be a
small Creator and make like a like a
middle class income by just making your
like cooking videos or whatever you know
by making just like
having a hundred thousand people who are
going to show up for your your videos
yeah and you know who knows that'll
change on YouTube but I hope at the very
least it's uh out of all different
platforms YouTube is one that very
clearly has a relationship with the
content creators on the platform you
know
but it's just yeah like Netflix makes
their own videos If Netflix just started
taking people's videos and like you know
oh that's a cool video you put on
whatever service it's fine now I'm gonna
put on Netflix people can pay a
subscription to watch it'd be like no
yeah yeah you can't do that but
apparently it's totally okay for
Facebook to do it and it's totally okay
for tick tock to do it you know it's
like into an extent it's totally okay
for Instagram to do it but like
yeah we just we're we're in this little
bit of a weird bump I think in like in
terms of art where it's like it's
becoming easier and easier and easier to
do and you have all these systems that
had to be built around creating this
because it was really expensive and hard
to do and you in ways it is still very
expensive and hard to do but like these
systems need that income to prop
themselves up and so like they're kind
of finishing their end game wherever
that end game is going and like this new
world kind of coming out but like you
have all these in between companies it's
like oh user generated content is a
thing but it's kind of janky so we don't
actually have to pay anybody for it but
they'll definitely grow our platforms
whoever can get the best user generated
content you get you know wins and like
right I think that bubble is gonna pop
in about five ten years and then you're
gonna have to see like they're gonna see
I think stuff like like either Netflix
or YouTube
really kind of dominating the scene
where it's like you know Netflix at a
certain point is just going to be
thousands of Executives hiring thousands
of filmmakers yeah at honestly normal
budgets you know like normal cable
television budgets to like make us a
show about this make us a show about
that which is basically what YouTube is
at this point just like a little bit
more middleman you know and that's cool
that's fine you know whatever great good
job you guys have a natural industry you
know YouTube's obviously taking another
slightly more algorithmic path but it
still boils down to
someone's gotta shake the hands of
Coca-Cola and sell the ads and someone's
got to shake the hands with the partners
you'll get the views you know it's
really not 100 automated like we we
obviously talk to YouTube reps all the
time you know it's it's a human to human
thing you know if you're somebody with a
thousand Subs you're not gonna be able
to talk to a YouTube rep but if you're
making real shows it's it's just a
slightly more algorithmized version of
what's happening on Netflix you know we
just have an executive producer calling
the shots they're just like hey if you
can get the views we'll give you the
budget it's like okay it's just like
slightly reversed
yeah
but we're getting close I mean you know
you guys demonstrated with this the
spiderverse video that like
we're getting close to a time when
somebody can go like I have a vision for
this world or for this character for the
style and a lot of it is just World
building it was like it's hard to build
worlds but I have a vision can I make it
a real thing and it's like we're getting
there yeah you know
Senator you have to be like a champion
at nuke and compositing not everybody is
you know which is not free which is also
not free yeah yeah I mean to be honest
that is like the the thing that makes
the video what it is is like your input
on that stuff where it's like otherwise
it would have just been Ah that's a cool
idea but like the Artistry that you
applied to it is what made it I think
the thing that it is thank you man yeah
I I disagree though because
the whole thing with it was that your
idea for it was it like we went out for
sushi if we talk with Nico and we came
up with a cool story and that's that's
what it was that was the Artistry of it
like it's again like nuke's just a tool
like DaVinci is like stable division
it's just it's just different ways to
enable you to do art nuke is kind of
prohibitedly expensive but it's um well
but now but Asian fusion which is built
into DaVinci Resolve and the similar
node-based compositor and like Nico and
I were talking about this morning
actually has some tools now which nuke
does not yeah magic mask is now built
into it yeah uh there's one other
automatic z-depth oh yeah automatically
depth Sky replacement Sky replacement
thing there's like some stuff built into
there and like I would be surprised if
nuke
reapproaches their licensing over the
next couple years yeah because there are
more visual effects artists than there
ever happened before and frankly with
every year that passes other companies
are starting to do things that adobe's
not doing like if Adobe doesn't reach
like feature parody with like DaVinci
Resolve the next year I'd they're gonna
start seeing a pretty big Exodus you
know it's like magic mask is a big deal
it's huge and like I can get you know a
year or two between like magic Mass
existing and DaVinci Resolve and like
after effects not having like the
equivalent but after that it's kind of
like downloading it's like it would be
like buying a 3D program and it doesn't
have Ray tracing it's like yeah but then
there's also the aspect of like like you
you edit your video together and then in
Premiere and then you send the shots out
to import into after effects and then
you export them out again and in resolve
you just click on the clip and you go
into your compositor like it's just a
tab and that that system
has like it's changed everything for for
us working on these Crew videos is like
you can actually do so much more now
because there's just again it's like
there's no the creative freedom is like
oh I want to make a cool illustration of
this thing I'll just click on that clip
and go into fusion and it's not it's not
prohibitive to be like okay I have this
amount of time
this after effect layers janky you know
whatever it is no it's just part of the
process yeah it's not this weird like
side quest you have to go and complete
your video it's it's so cool the tools
are getting way better and like every
year they're getting way better and it's
really wonderful to see and that it's
really important not to take it for
granted because I think everybody
everybody does like we all look at
computers we look at ai's like oh it's
gonna be so much better in two weeks you
know and it's like haha it it probably
will be but yeah you know it's funny but
in reality it's because people are
working their asses off you know and
like they're working hard in it and it's
not a guarantee that stuff does get
better and it's not a guarantee that new
tools come out it's just thankfully we
live in a world where people value it
and everybody's working hard to make new
tools everybody's working hard to share
information and like that's only going
to continue if people put in the work to
make it continue and the people who put
that out for free man huge process them
like who's the guy who created blender
or is the head guys blender super cool
Dutch dude yeah that Dutch dude is like
that guy's just a straight G and the
amount of money that guy has turned down
to for all the time splenders like
people tried to acquire it yeah he's
just like no it's like do you know how
many people would have just like I can't
learn three it's just I can't learn 3D
it's prohibitively expensive yeah and
blender's just like no it's actually one
of the best 3D programs available and
it's just free Unreal Engine the same
thing yeah oh my God thank God for
foreign engine is like literally the
Pinnacle of Mankind's like programming
ability yeah it's free and it's just
freaking yeah it's free and also just
was like a Savvy business move by them
to be like every artist go learn our
program yeah yeah I know that and then
now stable diffusion was a cost what
like 600
000 how like some well yeah crazy amount
of money it's important to be specific
Harris so the actual technique the
diffusion image creating technique is
one thing and that's created by I think
some University students and a guy from
runwayml
stability AI trained up a model yeah and
they spent six hundred thousand dollars
training that model yeah
um and they're trading more models and I
think that's the kind of business they
want to be is they want to be a model
business it's like you want a nice model
for rendering cars well I got the best
model right here right training 4K
Lamborghinis you know whatever you know
and honestly that in the future that's
where the value is going to be in
machine learning it's going to be in the
models it's like the code it's like cool
whatever you have like you have two
pages of code that like runs it through
machine learning algorithm like
whoop-dee-doo it's like the model that
you spent the past two months training
on 5000 gpus that's the thing that has
value yeah you know but so that was done
with stable diffusion 1.4 and 1.5 right
well it was it was a team effort once
again between Runway and stability and I
don't know the full details
part of me thinks that Runway got a
little overshadowed in this process
but yeah I guess what I'm saying is like
regardless there was all this money
spent on it and I can just download it
for free yes you know and that's the
crazy part is that again like unreal or
blender or all these programs it's like
they put all this work into it and it's
just like here you go you know we'll try
to figure out how to monetize this but
it's not like you know there's a bunch
of AI tools I see online where I'm like
I've seen a different version of this
that's free and you're trying to
re-package it for like 30 bucks a pop
you know and um it's just I love the
open source mentality and I like we just
want to get as many Gatekeepers out of
the way yes it's the jet ski versus the
big ship yeah especially with this kind
of stuff because it's so powerful it's
like you want it open you want people
learning like imagine math being like
behind a paywall you know it's like he's
like no I want to learn algebra does it
open source it yeah that's basically
what we have here I bet
we're going to redo a character
copyright ASAP it's about time because
at a certain point when you acknowledge
that somebody like Spider-Man it's just
it's in the cultural Mythos right yeah
and freaking Disney anybody can make
literally anybody right now can still
make a Spider-Man film nobody's stopping
anybody it's just you might not make any
money off it yeah it's just we only pay
attention to things when they're
actually good and I think that filter is
pretty strong like I've come to realize
that like oh you made it a cool like
official video game adaptation nobody
cares of it unless it's good like nobody
cares about the Paramount Halo series it
might as well not exist yeah like we've
already had multiple Halo series live
action up to this point anyways and like
nobody really cares about those either I
mean I take that back some people
obviously enjoyed some of the other
series but like point being is that if I
Turn to You and be like there's a new
there's an official Halo series coming
out you'd be like oh cool I wonder what
it looked like you'll be like oh it's
been done before yeah you know because
the others didn't really hit as long as
they look good yeah it's good it's good
yeah it doesn't matter if it's made by a
dude in his basement or it's made by
Disney it's like it only matters if it's
good you know yeah but Disney wants all
the money they want all the money they
want control over their ideas yeah they
want to control our entire
popular culture yeah dude if if you had
two options let's say let's say you're a
big old somehow you're a bigger business
than Disney
um
and you're gonna buy either Disney and
all of the IPS that they own don't
forget they own fox or
you can buy literally every other IP in
the world
which one would you pick Disney I'm
buying Disney I'm Disney yep because
Disney Disney's like a like an anime
villain we're like like 20 years ago
they were like your childhood yeah they
were like we have little girls in our
back pocket with these Princess
Characters but we don't have little boys
we'll just wait a little bit and then
you just that's like oh they just bought
Star Wars oh they just bought Marvel
yeah what's going on yeah and then
suddenly it's like every child is owned
by Disney now like everything they like
but you know what I Gotta Go Disney
props in one thing
and they still have this like this
little spark this little Ember deep in
their hearts the the spark of Walt
Disney still Burns ever so slightly
because they still seem to care it does
yeah
they still seem to care it's authentic
stuff inside's like but this is truly
for little girls and boys the most
precious things that we have yeah
have you guys seen the little the little
uh grogu like Studio Ghibli thing oh I
haven't watched no spoilers it's just a
little three minute clip that they
posted as a teaser oh man and
uh like I was like oh my God it's so
beautiful and it's so simple but it's
like it's it's true like I and we'll
we'll talk [ __ ] about the Marvel movies
a little bit but it's like there's still
something
special there and like a movie will come
out like Black Adam with the rock where
I'm like I'm a massive DC fan and I had
zero interest yeah because I was like
this is just a skin for a rock movie
yeah yeah
there yeah they just the rock as a
superhero yeah I mean we've talked to so
many people that worked on Disney stuff
and Marvel stuff it's like each person's
like incredibly talented and amazing in
their own right and it's like they're
all coming together and working on these
projects because it seems like Disney
somehow manages to hit that balance
between like hey we are business it does
matter but also
we are we are honest about our art you
know it's it's interesting like somehow
they have that plan
yeah but I think it's also the people
that putting in positions now like you
look at John Favreau and like Dave
filoni for the Star Wars stuff yeah
those are guys that love Star Wars yeah
and Dave specifically is like George
Lucas's straight up Padawan yeah and
it's but it means everything to him and
that even if not all of the new Star
Wars stuff is good they're still like
heart in it like some book above it
maybe not so much but then there were
two episodes it wasn't that bad they
were like hey Robert go make a show yes
because Spy Kids yeah um but man like
yeah watching Andor I'm just like Nico I
know I started 20 minutes then I started
this show you can relax I've started
watching it it just keeps getting it
better it's so freaking good and it's
yeah it's just it gives and it had no
right to be it was like this was the one
where I was like they're doing a show
about yeah the secondary character
pretty cool to the prequel yeah and it's
like we know he dies and he's not even
the the main character of the film and
it's like
it's just so good talk about World
building you know all that stuff and
maybe that's why it's good it's because
it's about the secondary character from
Rogue one and like doesn't it give
everybody all the executives are looking
elsewhere and they're probably like hey
we can make something now and then it
doesn't feel like Star Wars yeah and
it's not it's the best connected to like
any of the other stuff going on which so
much of the stuff even like Mandalorian
I loved and then it was like even as
much as I loved Luke showing up I was
like they're just doing that thing again
where it's like I know that but remember
but like the biggest like Connections in
Andor have been like oh there's a TIE
fighter like you know it's like and
because it's not like look all the Tie
fighters it's terrifying when a TIE
fighter shows up you're like oh crap
it's just like you have that that little
childhood thing of like oh cool I know
what a TIE fighter sounds like and then
when you're in a scene and you start to
hear that echoing through a valley in
the distance you're like yeah no it's
the Rogue one thing we were going
through a rogue one for that explosions
video yeah and it's the way that it's
not just that it's like oh I know that
thing it's the way it's presented is
like oh this is how it would really feel
like you know in Rogue one when the when
the Death Star comes up above the
Horizon so cool and it's like upside
down and you're like oh this is this is
what like that's terrifying yeah yeah
it's taking this like goofy Kids film
and being like we're gonna like this is
how a planet ending thing would actually
feel or like in this show it's like how
a rebellion would actually function in
order to like overthrow a fascist to
government you know yeah and it's uh
yeah I I am so that show that show and
also tells the Jedi which we've talked
about a little bit is like Star Wars is
firing on all cylinders right now I
don't want them to just let Dave filoni
and Tony Gilroy do everything yeah and
don't do anything
nevertheless like rise of Skywalker
under no circumstances ever dude like if
I like in stable you have your positive
prompts and your negative prompts I'm
gonna put in day floating Tony Gilroy
I'm positive and then and the
parentheses too yeah with tons of
parentheses and then a negative I'm
going to put rise of Skywalker with like
like 800 parentheses yeah yeah
it's cool too because Andor and tells
the Jedi could not be more different
yeah like and tales of the Jedi like
brings a bit of that like it's still for
kids which I think is so critical to
Star Wars and andor's totally not for
kids yeah so you still need to have that
right because it is for kids at the end
of the day but um
yeah they're really doing it really well
by the time we start making our own Star
Wars
yeah yep I don't mean that isn't like we
make a fan film
yeah let's just find a quick billion
dollar franchise no make our own
franchise no that's what I'm saying is
like we'll just pull out a quick you
know idea for that I actually don't
think it's that hard no I know it's like
it's like what but seriously I actually
don't think I said hard just takes
commitment and good writing and that's
it like again look at Brandon Sanderson
he's made whole universe I mean look at
George R Martin like he can't finish the
book but you know yeah yeah people just
want to see stuff that's good yeah like
just put me in a world yeah I don't care
like look how many cartoons are
successful yeah I just and like we're
saying like with this Tech the way it's
going it's like it's gonna allow us as a
small Studio to do something like that
you know yeah 100 really cool
yeah we gotta start writing and start
shooting yeah but you're working on it
so
all right I should go home and have
dinner
and watch Andor and watch Andor and
please yes watch Andor so we can talk
about it after dinner and I'm gonna
check on my stable diffusion dreambooth
model and then I'm gonna hit go on a
render
and then I'm gonna play Elden ring
I'm gonna go to sleep
that's a good night yeah there's I was
listening to an AMA with uh the CEO of
stability AI
and you know you could like and he's
just all these questions it's like right
in the thick of like all this drama they
had a few weeks ago
and somebody asked the questions like
it's like what do you like like to do
your free time it's like
I just want this to be in someone else's
hands so I can play Alden ring finally I
was like oh man I feel that oh yeah help
me with that new Halo update man dude
that's me with the Witcher wild Hunt and
Red Dead Redemption 2. came out haven't
installed don't even bother like I it's
Red Dead Redemption 2 is like glorious
but like the moment you start playing
you're like this is like I know there's
so little regard for my time yeah that's
what it is gonna be my like uh paternity
leave game like Calvin was born I bought
the game played the intro intro is cool
and it's like cool here's your Camp
here's a thousand things you can do and
it's like I ride my horse like 10
minutes to a creek and go fishing and
just uh yeah it's like just give me all
the guns let me start shooting everybody
it's like give me a two-hour experience
yeah yeah
so anyways I keep playing Elder drink
and I have 300 hours in that so to be
fair like 100 of those are leaving it on
overnight
yeah okay bye everybody thanks for
listening bye everyone